today we are here to talk about control
microscopy and to discuss how to use
that technique to the best possible
advantage in your research control
microscopy the technique is there to
take high resolution for us and images
of yourselves or tissues and anything
else that you may be happening to use as
a biological specimen and it does this
by eliminating alpha focus light so what
would you need to be doing can focal
microscopy for well probably most of you
may have some idea already because
you've been asked to do this and your
research confirm microscopy has a range
of applications and this is just a small
summary but there are many more wasters
and focal experiments you can use
confocal microscopy for localizing or Co
localizing different proteins and seeing
how they interact together so focal
microscopy can be used for him is like
imaging 2 3 or 4 for us and stains and
seeing which sort of parts of the
epitopes of proteins are interacting it
can be used to generate 3d images of
your sample and so you can actually look
at it in real space and see how
molecules distributed in the whole
volume or a whole organism it's possible
to use can focal for semi quantitative
measurements and so you can use it to
quantify protein expression or to do
comparative studies between proteins
when you've mutated them or if you
perturb them using Si RNA or drugs or
other inhibitors and finally what most
people tend to use can so-called
microscopy for us to acquire very high
quality images for presentation so it
can be really used to generate that
punchy image that will get your data
published or get people to come and look
at your poster when you're presenting it
so when would one need to use concise on
microscopy well there are limits to what
I can focal can do it can be used to
visualize structures between 200
nanometers and around 1 centimeter in
size which can be fluorescently labeled
this means it has applications and
standard cell biology tissue biology and
also single molecule imaging
applications
so next what I'm going to do is just
give you a little bit of a summary of
some of the areas that I'm going to be
talking about today and some of the
things that I'm hoping that you will
have an opportunity to learn about in
this webinar
first of all we'll be discussing how can
focal microscopy works what's inside the
machine and how come it generates these
high-resolution images with no
out-of-focus light and then going to be
talking about how the conferral
microscope generates multicolored images
and maybe some of the pitfalls that one
can fall into if you aren't careful the
setup I go to talk about collecting the
Zed stack for the 3d images in Caen
focal and that considerations you need
to have before you set that up and
finally I'm just going to go through
some of the questions that I routinely
hear as a core facility manager which
people have generally speaking when they
are sort of trying to do that in certain
images all started although obviously we
do have the Q&A session at the end so
please please do feel free to ask some
more questions there so first of all
what's the difference between
fluorescence and control microscopy why
would you want to do it I'm hoping that
this slide here would illustrate this so
as you can see here we've got an example
of sort of the structure inside the cell
as you can see with a wide field for
essence image it just sort of looks very
washed out and very yellow you can't see
much detail however when you look on the
confer call you start seeing a lot of
structure you would maybe say the
staining here and here or equivalent but
actually using the console when you
remove the outer focus light you can
start seeing no there are a lot of
different structures in here and there's
also sted space here that's black and so
your sample maybe isn't sustained in the
way that you would think it would be
this is an image of some cells file
junction proteins and here you may get
the impression that they're quite widely
distributed but actually when you look
using conferral microscopy S&C it's
quite discreet and so can focal
microscopy can actually be used to
remove some of the artifacts perhaps the
most telling image for why one would
need to use can focal microscopy versus
for essent microscopy is this image of a
pollen grain and with the wide field for
essence microscopy because of the outer
photo sites and the membrane around the
central pollen grain
above and below it the entire thing
looks red whereas actually with a
control microscope he's sectioned
through the middle of it and you can see
that inside there's this structure which
is stained with a different antibody and
that if in many respects why many people
choose can focus their tool of choice
when acquiring their images so how is it
that control images are clearer or why
is it the conferral microscope is so
complicated a lot of people in
facilities will be expected to go
through some fairly rigorous training
before there are let loose on the
confocal and the reason is really as
follows so your wide field FP present
microscope may look like a complicated
instrument but actually inside it's
fairly straightforward
you have a high pressure mercury layer
or clamp that sort of emits light
broadly across the spectrum so it emits
light of a range of different
wavelengths ranging from in the near UV
about 350 nanometers all the way through
to 800 nanometers this light is shone
into your sample and there's out the
focus lights as one's in focus light
there and then it's reflected by the
dichroic mirrors down through the
objective onto your sample the sample
obviously is thick it's not thin it's
not one atoms thick in general if it's a
cell it will be a few microns thick and
so what happens is then the light is
emitted from the sample and you'll have
the focus light from your point of
interest but out-of-focus light around
it as well this goes back through the
objective and through the object to
desire a mirror up to your camera so the
image at the camera contains the InFocus
light from your sample and also the
out-of-focus light and that can be the
cause of the haze and the images that
you saw in the previous slide so how
does control microscopy work well
essentially this was designed by a chap
called Minsky in the 50s and it was a
real breakthrough he established that if
you use these things called pinholes
which are basically small metal pieces
of equipment with an adjustable size
hole in the front you can actually use
it to cut out to the outer focus light
so you instead of having a mercury vert
bulb you have to have a laser and that
there's a lot of in focus and outer
focus light but there's only a small
amount of in focus light compared to the
art effects light so you need to use a
high-intensity light source when you're
starting to image your samples so this
is generally done from lasers of a
defined wavelength the laser light is
shown in the selected down to your phone
in the same way by the dichroic mirror
onto your sample now of course even
though later like going in is in focus
when you get your sample you will have a
volume excited and so the light that is
emitted by your sample will contain some
in focus and some out-of-focus light
this will be refracted through your
objective which may create a few more
aberrations in your image and then it
comes up to the detector now before the
detector this is a bit weather can phone
call really does its business if there's
a pinhole and the distance of the
pinhole fan detector and the objective
has been very carefully calculated so it
is in the conjugate plane from the
sample which is a focal pane so this
pinhole is in the confocal plane as in
the opposite to the focal plane now if
you know about what wavelengths of light
that's being emitted from your sample
you know what to expect
you can also know how big the wavelength
of the light in focus is and you know
that distance of the wavelength so then
you can set the pinhole up so it is
exactly that's length or that size and
that means a pinhole will cut out the
out-of-focus light emitted by your
sample will only have the in focus like
present and that's great because you
only have your in focus light but again
similarly to the light source in the
first place this means that most of the
light is actually removed by the pinhole
and there's only a small amount of in
focus light that reaches is etcetera so
the detector needs to be more sensitive
than the average camera and in general
what people use is photomultiplier tube
and so this will sort of collect samples
point by point as a light comes in and
then it will sort of feed it back to the
computer where the image is built up so
just to recap what does a pinhole do its
primary aim is to remove the
out-of-focus light the pinhole is
adjustable that's important because
obviously the size of
the pinhole will depend on the objective
lenses that use and the wavelength of
the light so if you're using short
wavelength light then the pinhole will
need to be fairly small because the
wavelength is short if you're using
something a longer wavelength like red
dyes and the pinhole will need to be
larger because a wavelength is longer
and to make life easy for us so it's
very helpful optical physicists to
decided to measure the pinhole size in
every unit rather than expecting us to
do all the maths for ourselves so on
your control call it will say that a
pinhole is measured as one and that
means that just the InFocus light is
imprint is present and looking focal
microscope in general will know which
objective lens you're using and what
wavelength of light you're using you
will tell it that when you set it up so
it will be able to calculate for you how
big the pinhole needs to be set and
you've got some power to adjust that as
you choose
so just to recap the white is that you
need lasers you need a more intense
light source because you've cut out all
of your out-of-focus light and so
there's only the in focus light which
isn't a great deal and then a similarly
that means that the detectors there's
only the in focus light and so you need
to spend much more sensitive detector
usually this is photomultiplier tubes
but sometimes this can be EMC CD cameras
as well so how does the control core
actually collect your image what does it
actually do it doesn't just sort of
shine the light and then it goes into
the detector it's more complicated than
that people who have got some experience
with conferral microscopy will know that
collecting and control image can take a
little bit of time compared to taking a
wide field image and this is how this
happens but basically in kanne focal
microscopy you're select your sample and
bring it into focus and then the Machine
will sort of place a virtual grid over
your sample each cell in the grid is
called a pixel you can decide for
yourself how many pixels there are the
focal default to certain sizes but you
can actually select that so you can
choose how big or small the pixels are
for yourself and then what happens next
is a confer call or scan
pixel-by-pixel your image as illustrated
in the bottom side here by the yellow
light which is a laser light coming
across scanning pixel by pixel across
your sample and collecting the laser
light the lights the that's in focus
from that given pixel this then goes to
this chapter and builds up the image now
as you can see if I'm clicking through
in a webinar this is not a very fast
process and so that's why your confer
call will take a little longer to
generate light than your normal sample
and this point scanning is one of the
major courses of issues and some con
social experiments this is because the
laser light is very intensely shining on
a very small point of your sample for a
period of time and that can cause from
the thrust dyes that if you've used to
label your sample to photo bleach and so
one of the more important things you
need to consider when you're doing
conferral microscopy is how you prepare
your sample in the first place it's
important that you use lights which are
known to be bright and the technical
term for this is quantum yield and the
quantum yield is defined as how many
photons you get out of your present die
compared to the photons that you get in
so if you get lots of photons out of
your die it will have a high quantum
yield and it's ideal for using some
focal microscopy so Alexa fluor duck
dies for instance are very good at this
so basically if you want to improve your
console image quality then there's a
couple of things that you can do
generally speaking when you start
imaging on a console it will default to
a fast scanning mode which you use to
optimize the laser power and the
sensitivity to the date detector however
the speed of the portlet point scanning
of the laser can be varied and the
slower that you scan your laser cross
the less noise that you get because
obvious you leaving your laser to dwell
on an individual pixel for a little
longer however obviously if you leave
your laser sitting on a point like this
described by my laser pointer if you
leave it for too long you end up burning
a hole in it and so there's a bit of
trade-off there so you may need to slow
your laser pointer your laser scanning
down a little
but too much and your little sample it's
also possible to make the laser scan an
individual pixel in your image more than
once and then display the average of
this this averaging again reduces the
noise and increases the signal and so by
slowing down the laser speed and also
increasing the averaging of your pixels
will increase the signal and decrease
the noise producing a really beautiful
image like this illustrated here so how
would one optimize the image acquisition
well the first thing you need to do is
check whether or not your image is
saturated or under sampled and on the
left-hand side here I'm indicating an
image which is saturated in the sampled
generally speaking your control core
software there will be some button that
you'll need to press to show whether the
pixels are saturated and the sampled
each control call is different each
manufacturer has got separate software
so you need to contact your controls
manufacturer or somebody who's more
experienced in using that and focal to
find out which button that is generally
speaking the saturated pixels show up as
red and the under sampled one surface
blue and it's best practice to have no
pixels that are saturated or under
sampled in your image because then
you're truly showing all of your data
and so even if the black background is
black well it if it's black by eye then
if it's not under sample then it comes
up black then you're truly showing
what's there you're not excluding that
data and similarly if you've got some
structures there's a quite intense you
need to try if you can to get them
within the range of the detector and so
you know you're showing the full dataset
and you're not kind of hiding anything
that's the best scientific practice but
make sure your sample is not bleached by
the confocal which is very easily
happened the best way to do it is to set
the laser power as low as you possibly
can get away with and this may still be
reasonably high depending on your sample
but you need to try and minimize the
laser power so it doesn't bleach your
sample the detector should be set at
appropriate sensitivity so the specimen
is neither over sampled or under sampled
and so it's fully within the linear
range of what the detector can do
and the backgrounds in my opinion should
be in the linear of the range of the
detector but it should be black so now
we move on to the next part of the
seminar which is preparing your sample
for multicolor for confocal imaging and
as you can see here we've got some
excellent images of neurons and
different like kind of small cells in a
piece of tissue which has been labeled
beautifully for multicolor imaging and
it's possible for anybody to acquire
images of this quality so when you're
setting up conferral scanning of
multicolor images first of all you need
to understand properties of the dyes
that you are using and so you need to
understand what the excitation or
absorption spectrum of your diet and
what the emission spectrum is as well
from this information you should know
then which lasers you will need to use
to excite it and which detectors will
need to be in place or which filters
will be need to be in place to detect
the dyes now in the average filter can
focus which are available on the market
right now
there will be preset for common
combinations so people who are sorts of
imaging something with Dappy something
blue
but in green something red there will be
a preset combination for that although
it is important for you to understand a
little bit more especially about what
you're using and I'll discuss that later
generally when a control call scans
multicolor images you can set it to each
channel separately and then emerge
channel and that's important because you
will need to align the detectors for
each of the channels that you're imaging
not just the merge and so you need to
make sure that the green the red and the
blue within the linear range of the
detector on the console call when you're
acquiring your data for best practice
what will happen is in the merged images
the signal is from separate channels is
in the same pixel if you remember the
confocal divides up your image into a
pixel so if there's some port there's a
signal from two different channels in
the same pixel it will show up as yellow
as defined here so just to recap before
we go forward so I think it's the best
if I review the four essence entry and
so basically stress in theory works like
this your laser light shines in and you
have your dye which is sitting in a
ground state
the excitation later comes in the dye
absorbs some of the light it jumps up
into a high-energy excitation state and
the problem is then with a present dies
that it gets stuck and so it can't just
drop back down to the ground state it's
got a problem it's got to find a way of
losing the energy somehow so what it
does is it vibrates it both sort of
knocks itself into the surrounding
molecules it loses some of the energy is
heat a bit and then there it comes down
to a slightly lower energy state and it
falls back down to the ground state
there's a difference between the
energies that it needed to be excited
and the energy that it will emit when it
absorbs so the photon that needs to
excite it will be of high energy it will
lose through this energy and then the
photon that's emitted will be of lower
energy so that means when you're kind of
doing any sort of imaging you will tend
to have one color light that's shining
in to excite your sample and then when
you look down the eyepiece what you'll
see will be a different color and that's
why so this sort of describes the
excitation spectra and what you need to
be looking at something that I commonly
have as a question in my kind of
facility is you know what is all of this
and basically a dye will not be excited
at only one wavelength it will be
excited across a weight range of
wavelengths and so this is Alexis or 488
and as you can see it's excited
maximally around 488 nanometers but it's
also excited at 450 slightly and it's
excited slightly at 520 as well however
if you're shining in a light laser light
at 488 you're going to get about 75% of
the emission e.x sort of molecules being
excited by that light
similarly with it like a dice such as
elect four five six eight you see that
when you shine in a laser light of five
and sixty-eight animated about sixty
percent of that dye will be excited at
that wavelength what is useful when
you're comparing the excitation spectra
between these two different wavelengths
is if you look at the 488 dye and then
you look at the five six eight weight
laser none of the 488 dyes excited by
the fire
six-eight wait laser and that's quite
important you need to have some sort of
separation there and there are two
online tools that can help you do this
more of a problem is emission spectra
and so this is what the range of
wavelengths over which your dye will
emit when it falls down to that lower
energy level and drops back down to the
ground state
so the 488 laser worklight will from the
dye will emit between 500 and actually
all the way up to 650 nanometers ever so
slightly but by 550 most of the of the
emission pasts are fallen off similarly
5 6 8 most of the emission is kind of
occurring at 600 nanometers but there's
a bit at 550 and then it's emitting
still at 700 nanometers just not
particularly much so what does that mean
that means that there is an overlap in
the emission spectra here between the
488 and the 5 6 8 dyes and that will
mean that when you're setting your
microscope up if you're not careful you
might get some of the signal of the 5 6
8 coming through into the 488 channel
now this may look a bit complicated in
theory but the next slide I will show
you in practice this is what it looks
like so this is an Alexa fluor 488 to
dye and this is an Alexa 4 5 6 8 dye and
what's happened here is that they
haven't been careful about how they set
up what does that light that they
collected so some of the light from the
488 has actually come through into the 5
6 8 and so what you see in this channel
is it looks like that this protein is
everywhere however actually if your care
more careful about how you set it up so
you separate out to the 488 from the 5 6
8 specifically you see that the 488 is
indeed in the middle of the cells but if
you are collecting only the light
emitted by Alexis or 5 6 8 you will see
that this protein is only present at the
cell so all
orders and not in the middle of the cell
and so problems with not managing the
bleed through can really cause
misinterpretation of the data and that's
quite a serious thing so it's very
important that you understand how you
set up the filters or the detectors on
your machine to specifically pick up the
range of wavelengths that you're trying
to measure and know more so how can I
have comfo call help with this spectral
overlap well one way it does it is by
sequential scanning and so this is done
so each channel can focal is set to
collect it's done separately so it will
do the green channel first and then the
red Channel and this is usually sent two
seconds apart it's very very quick so
you don't have to sit there for minutes
and then when you're doing the
sequential scanning you can choose to
scan either the whole image or one line
of the pixels of an image so you can see
either the whole thing or have both
channels filled up the line by line it
is possible to remove image using
simultaneous scanning and that's where
all the lasers on the conferral are
scanning at once the issue with this is
obviously you get the bleed through but
the advantage is it's much quicker it
just depends on what you're trying to do
one compromise is using mix of scanning
and this means that you scan using two
lasers and detect using two detectors
when you know that there's no spectral
overlap between the channels and so one
common combination that people use for
this is dyes alexa fluor 488 so it dyes
are excited by 488 nanometers and then
alexa 463 or lex for six or seven and
these two dives don't interact with one
another what at all and so it makes it
very easy to detect both of these
simultaneously without any bleed through
occurring so this is just an example of
what the difference between sequential
and simultaneous scanning is and just to
sort of repeat this the way you scan
your images can give very different
results when it's important to check how
you're doing it before you start so here
this image is just the alexa fluor 488
die this image is just side three and if
you sequentially scan you can see that
the kind of combination of the two does
give you the separate separated I've
refused simultaneously scan then they
overlap and so in the merged image which
is d it may look like the signal
co-localize but this is really an
artifact of incorrect confederal setup
so if you're studying co-localization of
your proteins it's essential that you
set up sequential scanning to present
this interpretation of data also when
you're preparing your sample for kin
focal and particularly when you're doing
co-localization you need to ensure that
each episode is separately labeled and
have very spectral et cetera excitation
and emission spectra the conferral have
filter field eyes and so they can be
specifically separated in the light path
it's also important for you to include
certain controls if you want to be
really sure and really rigorous about
the way you're doing your experiment so
you need to include some kinds of
positive control for the fluorophore
that you're imaging if you aren't sure
whether the antibody is going to work so
maybe an antibody that does work or dyes
it works you would need to include some
kind of negative control sustaining and
imaging people will often just have the
secondary on its own to see if the dye
that's been using a secondary antibody
promiscuously binds somewhere where it
shouldn't serve or biological faint
samples are Auto for essence especially
brain tissue where you have a lot of
NADH and those Flavin's are very
threatened and so it's useful to include
a sample with no staining so you can
actually set up your detector so they're
not collecting any of this Auto for
essent background it's also advisable to
set up controls for spectral bleed
through so you have only one episode
episode labels and then you collect use
and control call in both channels so say
for instance you were looking for a
experiment where you're looking at a
localization between a green channel and
the red Channel you would need to have a
control where you'd only got a little
488 which emits in the green
and then image that and see what comes
up in the red if something comes up in
the red channel you know that there's a
problem with the way the machines set up
and so you need to alter the parameters
on the red channel detection there was a
green alone you see nothing in the red
Channel and you need to do that
experiment the other way around so with
a red alone and being sure that you see
nothing in the green Channel people
sometimes also include an ISO type
control to ensure that the Sailing is
really specific if it's something is
really unexpected and I would strongly
advise people to ensure that their
samples are collected using sequential
scanning okay so now I'm going to hand
over to Miriam who is going to present
you a short quiz so I've an mentioned it
is quiz time so let's see how good your
fluorochromes knowledge is so here your
first three questions and here's your
next one
so thank you very much for taking part
the axe the answers will be revealed
before the Q&A session and before I'm
healing back the microphone to one who
will take you through the second part of
the webinar I would like to encourage
you to submit more microscopy related
questions thank you very much Miriam
that was great very helpful so now we
need to talk a little bit more about
collecting some of those really
beautiful three-dimensional images on
the comfo chol as you can see from this
example here of a developing SEPA fish
embryo it's possible for you to swap or
several whole organisms and quite a lot
of detail and you'll be able to rotate
them around and actually really see how
the structures look inside the sample
however there's a couple of
considerations that you need to make
before you setup your 3d imaging so if
we go back to that theory that we
discussed at the beginning of the
session the control my pinhole reboot
moves the out-of-focus light from the X
and the y plane so just one flap pain
well actually it does a little bit more
than that it removes these other focus
right from the axial plane or the z
plane I'm going to call it in this talk
for ease so you can see here this is an
example of your InFocus light and there
are x y&z components to it the pinhole
will move the out-of-focus light from
all of these and this means that it's
possible to use a confocal microscope
providing stage moves to image the whole
of the volume of an object in 3d without
any other focus like presence one thing
I will describe now as commonly used
terminology is the acquired confer call
X Y Z section is called an optical
section so the optical section is not
completely flat like a thin piece of
paper it's actually sort of more like a
cube in a shape and thickness of the
optical section is determined by three
things and the American aperture of the
objective which is how much light is let
through it the conferral pin Howell size
which is how much in focus light is
there
and the wavelengths of light and the
numeric aperture of the objective will
sort of basically is something that
describes how well the objective gathers
light with a specimen it explodes
distance every single objective will
tell you what its numeric aperture is on
it so this is a generic objective here
you can see the magnification is
described there this is a numeric
aperture and so the higher that number
the better at gathering light the
objective is and you need to find out a
bit about the numeric aperture of your
objective to find out how good it's
going to be at collecting optical
sections before you start your 3d
imaging experiments so to collect your
control volume you need to have ideally
as much of the information as you
possibly can about the image and so the
optical sectioning must be ideal in the
x y and z axis so you need to find out
for your objective how thick your
optical section is going to be and then
you need to set the increment that the
stage moves to be pretty much the same
as the optical section to collect all of
the light that's there but you can
produce your 3d image which is truly
representative of what it is and that
information you may not know of pops
your head but your microscope
manufacture may be able to tell you as
an example here I've got some
information about the sort of objective
you have this numeric aperture and then
the optical effects face thickness given
that the pinhole is one so you can see
for a 10x objective with a numeric
aperture of naught point three which is
quite low the optical slice section is
actually quite fat it's 11 microns and
so obviously if you've got something
very thin then you probably aren't even
going to need to do is s that what will
be present in your one slice it's all
the information that you need about your
sample if you go up to higher power
objectives and higher numeric apertures
you can see the slice of the opticals
they set the size of the optical slice
drops off so when you're using a 63 X
oil objective if you have a high numeric
aperture such as one point for the
optical section six
is point three microns so then of course
that depends on how big your sample is
and it's large like that zebrafish you
may need quite a few sections to collect
all of the in focus light in that sample
to render your 3d volume and so the ways
that I would advise people to set up
control volume imaging is to set your
microscope to start collecting the dead
sizes right at the top of your sample
and you should have no light in focus at
that point so the specimen should be
just out of focus at the top and then it
should move through all the way down to
the bottom where there's no InFocus
light at the bottom either if you're
going to try and collect the percept 3d
section you'll need to scan with the
optimal size optimized and that may take
some time and so that's sort of really
the ideal way of collecting your 3d
sections so now I'm just going to move
on and talk about some of the common
questions I get asked in my course
acidity when people start using concer
core microscopy so the first question I
get asked by people who've never done
any conferral before is when I look down
the microscope and it sets the scan on
the control call I can't see anything
and there's a good reason for that
because the laser light is so powerful
it would damage your eyes if you look at
it and so if you need to see your
samples on the microscope you need to
ensure that the light part is set to
your eyes if it is and you can't see
anything then it may well be that your
sample staining hasn't worked when you
like to confer Kermode if you can't see
anything and that's a good thing because
that means that the lasers aren't
actually going to go to your eyes and if
you can see something then you need to
contact your microscope manufacturer
immediately the second question is while
I'm imaging my swamp or fades away and
that's to do with the fact that the
lasers on the consoler sets very high
power and so they can sometimes bleach
or die that you're using so the best way
of avoiding that there's nothing you can
do in your samples bleach the staining
has gone but maybe in a different place
on the same slide you might have another
opportunity to acquire some images
and the thing to do there is make sure
that the detectors are set to maximum
sensitivity and the lasers are on the
minimum power possible that way you will
minimize the bleaching in your sample
let's confirm people often have is the
sample looks really dim now if your
sample looks really dim by eye then the
staining is weak and the conferral will
need optimizing and so you know you may
need to have your detectors on maximum
sensitivity and use the laser a little
bit more powerfully than possible to
just get any sort of image although you
do need to be remembered that you need
to be representing your data fairly and
so producing something that's dim on the
slide is probably the right thing to do
if the same thing that was really bright
by eye and you need to be honest about
this the Texas made me to be made more
sensitive because maybe it's just been
left by the previous user in a place
where they had to wait staining and your
failings not the famous lab so you'll
need to re optimise the machines but I
will reiterate the point that it's very
important to take a representative image
of your sample if you're looking focal
and your sample looks really grainy that
might be because of caen focal is still
in its initial fast scan mode which uses
for you to optimize the detectors and
make sure that everything is within the
linear range of the detector so it's not
saturated or under sand board and what
you can do is you can actually choose to
slow down the scan speed on your control
core and also increase the averaging of
the frames and so this means that by
slowing down and letting the laser dwell
on each pixel for a little longer and by
averaging maybe two or four frames
you'll cut down this grainy noisiness
and you'll really get a nice looking
image the last question is a tricky one
you think you see Canseco localization
in your sample but your mentor your PI
or your group leader your postdoc or
whoever doesn't agree with you so if you
just show one image as a co-localization
then you know it's sort of not quite
enough ready to make a robust scientific
case what you need to have when you're
presenting co-localize data is
all of the controls present for your
staining and you need to make sure that
you're capturing your images using the
same settings on the control call that
you use for the confer kind of controls
and so you need to have an image of just
the green on its own and then nothing in
the red channel the red channel on its
own nothing in the green channel it's
also very important to set the
instrument up using sequential scanning
okay so this is the end of the bit of
the webinar where I'm talking about
theory and I'm just going to summarize
what I said soken focal microscopes are
there to remove that to focus light and
produce high-quality images the focal
microscopes mostly work by point
scanning and they'll scan each image
point by point and speed and the
averaging on your control can be altered
to improve your image quality sequential
scanning is important to stop one die
bleeding through into another channel
and that's very important when you're
setting up a co-localization experiment
controls can be used to reconstruct 3d
volumes but it's very important to
understand how particular optical
section is and a little bit more
information about the objective and its
numeric aperture at the pinhole when
you're setting up your 3d volumes so now
I'm going to hand over to Miriam to give
us a summary of the products and
services which are available thank you
very much and for such an informative
and detailed seminar hello again
everyone I would like to take this
opportunity to tell you a bit about
after microscopy resources and products
that can help you to improve yourself
imaging experiments Gravatt monoclonal
or Rapp maps offer high affinity and
specificity which results in high
sensitivity and low background staining
this makes them ideal affinity reagents
for demanding applications such as IHC
or formerly in part of them and better
tissues to give you the best experience
each web map has been tested on multiple
human tissue arrays for IHC and on
multiple samples for ICC is braaap maps
also offer diverse epitope recognition
of human protein targets and the mouse
also looks so there is no need to
generate a separate through a gated
antibody because they are rabbit
generated they are ideal for use of
masks rats who run a mouse over a tissue
samples they can also be easily paired
with mouse or rat monoclonal antibodies
for simultaneous training for further
information please visit at comic-con
slash web maps for staining with your
web maps we recommend one of our alexa
fluor conjugated secondary antibodies
405 five six eight and seven four zero
all these secondary antibodies have been
extensively tested in the Occam
laboratories in order to guarantee blood
staining and low background the
selection of Prieto antibodies it's
large and ensures low species cross
reactivity the dilution range for all
these products is between one in 200 and
one in thousand and the products are
very competitively priced to find out
more go to up cam comm slash alexa ab
cam catalog also includes a whole range
of cell imaging tools for multi colors
painting discover our site to paint a
range of kids and reagents for staining
actin filaments ER Golgi mitochondria
and lysosomes in multiple colors it is
an easy way to study colocalization
without having to fiddle around with
multiple antibodies try to painted
products can be used in combination with
secondary antibodies and nuclear dies
the image on the top right corner shows
you an example of multicolor staining of
mouse embryos bodies and if you want
trouble-free staining of nuclei why not
try our fire red dyes that will display
nuclear staining in just five minutes
included in this range are drug files
and drug 7 which can be used for
staining live or fixed cells
respectively
here in the bottom image you can see
nuclei stained with drugs 7 while the
blue staining originates from an anchor
conjugated secondary antibody our
extensive portfolio of validated
secondary antibodies for cell imaging
includes pre adsorbs Alexa and I alike
conjugated secondary antibodies for
minimal species cross reactivity our
range also includes chromeo conjugated
secondary antibodies for spent
microscopy and up called conjugated
secondary antibodies for high resolution
electron microscopy to increase the
penetration in IAC experiments we
recommend you to try one of our sub to
fragment antibodies and for non
fluorescent imaging or enzymatic
detection ab cam also offers a
comprehensive range of products for
immunity chemistry included in the
portfolio are exposed by eight circuits
which provide greater sensitivity in
comparison to polymer and ABC notation
systems through smaller detection
complex the IC portfolio also includes
the classical biotene acceptable in kids
and ancillary reagents if you would like
to know more about all this range of
cell imaging products please visit up
cannot come slash imaging where you can
find more information a son has
mentioned during the webinar it is very
important to protect your slides from
photo bleaching for these specific
purpose upcam offers a range of flora
shield mounting reagents these are
available with or without nuclear dose
touches the p and p i actual scientific
support team is here to answer any
questions you may have the team members
are multilingual
and also support in a range of languages
including French Spanish German Chinese
and Japanese you can contact them in the
US UK
Kong and Japan on the email addresses
and phone numbers shown here you can
also listen to all our past webinars
including other microscopy related ones
such as how to design multicolor
explaining and how to design IHC ICC
experiments quite simply going to Afghan
comm slash webinars and now the power
you have been waiting for the answers to
the quiz the correct answers are shown
in bold so for question 1 which floor
Akram is not typically used in
microscopy
the answer is PE or FICO in Turin this
toy exists in b2 as a 240 kilo Dalton
protein with 23 fico in troubling coma
force per molecule PE is the boy to
florrum for flow cytometry but since
it's highly photobleach able it is
unsuitable fluorescent microscopy so
question - which color combination will
most likely give you the spectral
overlap the answer is a mainly because
the fluorochromes alexa 5 5 5 and 6 4 8
have quite high spectral overlap and for
question 3 which of the below solo
chromes
have the highest quantum Jill the
correct answer is Alexa 488 as it has a
quantum yield of point 92 so it's very
close to 1 and I would like to finish by
thanking and again for such an
interesting webinar and all of you for
attending so now I'm is happy to answer
any of your questions
thank you very much Miriam I've got a
few minutes to answer some of the
questions that you've all kindly emailed
in so the first question I'd like to
answer are what are the criteria for a
good quality image from control
microscopy for publishing which is an
excellent question the first thing
that's probably the most important is it
needs to be very representative of your
saw
so you need to make sure that maybe not
only just you but you and somebody else
maybe your supervisor or colleague in
your lab agrees that what you see down
the microscope is what is also being
seen by the image that is produced on
the can focus something that you will
need to know when you're trying to
publish your image it kind of
application quality is that it needs to
be a high resolution it needs to be
about 300 dpi otherwise it will look
kind of grainy and not see when you
actually upload it on to the website for
the publication it's quite important
these videos will be put in your paper
and they'll come out a lot smaller than
what you see on the control screen so
it's quite important to sort of really
make sure you've got that polishing
there you need to make sure the
background is properly black if you can
try and exclude any artifacts of the
image so it might be possible for you to
turn around the area that you're
scanning on the conferral a little so
you can exclude anything you don't want
if you've got a nasty blob of rubbish
that's unfortunately ended up next to
your perfect cell or tissue do make sure
that everything is put in a linear range
of your detector make sure your
background is black but it is linear in
the detector and nothing is saturated
and try and improve to focus as much as
possible so you would want to slow down
the scanning speed and also include the
averaging for a publication quality
image the next question is how can you
tell the difference between auto for
essence and week staining and that's a
great question that's a very difficult
one to answer and you know it's posed
quite a lot of problems I think for
people the best way of doing that is
actually by just having control where
there is nothing
feigned and so you just have your tissue
or yourself all controls that I've ever
worked with have got a bright field
option and so what you can do is you can
focus your sample by bright field and
you can even get looking focal to
require a bright field image for you
generally and then you can just acquire
an image of
the tarpaulin brightfield so it's in
focus and then having the settings for
the concert all set up requiring which
is whichever diet is you were going to
acquire so let's go for it
just take the image with nothing there
and see how the other person's looks
what you don't need to do is obviously
use those settings if you can see
nothing you have to optimize them for
the opposite minimize and then you can
actually take your image there's the
advanced tools called spectral and
mixing which is possible to do with
certain console's I'll just mention the
contact the concepts of spectral and
mixing here I won't go into it in detail
because it's an advanced application
however if you can look on the wet
internet for this there's plenty of
resources available for it online and it
may be possible if you're fortunate
enough to work in the managed facility
that your facility manager may know
about spectrum and mixing usually the
emission spectra for the auto for
essence is slightly different from the
emission spectra from the dye that
you're using and so you can collect the
emission spectra from the also
fluorescence and remove that but that
that can be a little bit more demanding
to do but it is certainly possible to
differentiate between auto flesh and
some weak staining and what I try and
recommend is you optimize your straining
as much as you possibly can to try and
get it a bit brighter it's possible so I
just have any question for somebody
asking what is a parameter pixeled well
so if we go back to the side in the
presentation when we're talking about
your image what happens is all the way
to control Z this is a series of little
boxes and the boxes are called pixels
and the laser is moving across the image
pixel by pixel and pixel dwell is
basically the length of time that the
laser is sitting on a given pixel before
it moves so if it's sitting there for a
millisecond or a microsecond that will
sort of depend on you kind of how your
image looks
usually the longer the pixel sits on a
given point so the longer the dwell time
noise is but the board transfer is of
your sample being bleached somebody else
asked can I do the convolution of light
images on the confocal microscope
certainly you can and for some
applications it's worthwhile bothering
so if you're really pushing the limits
of the resolution of what your control
can do so if you're trying to image
something that's about 200 nanometers
and you're trying to do a 3d volume of
this for instance for imaging the
nucleus then you may want to try and do
something on volution the convolution in
principle is there to remove
out-of-focus light the kabocha pinhole
in practice is also there to remove
out-of-focus light so really you only
need to deconvolve your images if you're
a bit uncertain as to if there are any
out-of-focus light remaining in your
consult images when you're done with
your control core microscopy some people
choose to do this others don't
I generally advise not to do it and
that's it's something very very specific
in details and it's right at the limit
of resolution of a confocal but I'd say
that it's about something that's really
down to you your group leader and others
in your group of how things happen in
your field okay so I think we may have
time for a couple more questions so I
have a question saying do all dyes emit
at the same wavelength as very excited
with well for essence the answer to that
question is no they don't
so chromogenic dyes which is a thought
that's used for histology like H&E
generally speaking they they're just
sort of little kind of chemicals and
they emit light if you shine normal
light at them you don't they will be a
color and you'll be able to see that
thrusted eyes aren't like that they're
different and so basically the present
dyes excited by a high-energy lights
also absorb high-energy photons and
it has to do some of the energy because
of the way the design structures and
then it needs to emit light at a lower
wavelength so person's eyes emit Y light
at different wavelengths from the light
that don't sighted from and the
wavelengths that they emit at depends on
the chemistry of the dye so you need to
go back and check out what the
absorption or excitation spectra of your
dyers and their what its emission
spectrum is before you can set things up
and somebody else's please can you
explain the order of use of the color
channels in Caen focal well to be honest
I would say that depends on the
instrument that you're using usually
people will collect the sort of the
shortest wavelength first so they'll
collect the blue channel first and then
the green and the red but really what
happens is when you're simultaneously
scanning they are all collected all at
the same time and then the light is
split about by the dichroic mirrors
which are in the emission light path and
so the dichroic light will send some
wavelengths in one direction and other
wavelengths in other directions and if
you're using some will state in the fuel
using sequential staining then basically
it will collect blue green or red
whichever order that you put it in
really and it's kind of up to you really
the control will be preset certain
channels and if it's easier when you're
starting to use irken focal to start off
with then just use the presets that will
be the first advice that I have okay so
the last question is can control be
useful for M'Lynn or and
paraffin-embedded tissue or just frozen
tissue the answer to that question is it
can be used to both for formula and
paraffin-embedded tissue it's a little
bit more tricky to do the setup you need
to do some sort of antigens
trevore step there are protocols
available for this I think this may be
competent other ab cam webinars so i
wouldn't be able to advise in detail
about this now but it certainly is
possible to do - you just need to be
quite careful about how you set up that
I can so for microscopy but
either sample will work and we have
published that okay right well thank you
very much for all of your questions and
thank you for your time